[Music]
hello everyone this is games you should
know by heart and I'm Dennis boorish
today we're going to talk about
something
most of the chess players are interested
in and that's AI artificial intelligence
and more specifically computer chess the
game match played between stockfish and
google off of zero now when I was
thinking about this lecture I thought
about AI and my first thought was Blade
Runner the movie in nineteen made in
1982 when the professor sat down and
played professor tyro started playing
with Sebastian but Sebastian used some
device he shouldn't have a replicant so
basically he was playing advanced
gesture of some sorts because beatty
replicant is a creative structure and
artificial intelligence that helped
Sebastian beat the doctor now whenever
whenever I was thinking of this match I
realized that they that alpha 0 is much
like baby alpha 0 is just like me Hall
tau built as a computer so let's take a
look first at the game played by tau so
this is one of many famous games of me
how tall the 8th world champion and I'll
show this game because with this you'll
understand that office 0 is basically
playing chess like tau just with a
little bit more hardware Knight f3
Knight of 6 c4 e6 Knight see
3d 5d for ironically this way of
transposing also happens in office zeros
games he also plays Knight f3
starting with her ad and turning into a
main line opening c6 Bishop g5 d takes
c4 e 4 B 5 this is the bottleneck
variation but Tao doesn't want to get
into main lines he goes in his own way
and plays a 4 now this is kind of
annoying because if you play b4 for
example I'll just play Knight be one
drop back I plan to go to an ID 2 and
pick up the pawn on c4 so Keller really
doesn't have a choice he plays Queen b6
now top takes on f6 G takes f6 Bishop b2
a6 castle this should be 7 not Tom makes
a very very classical breakthrough
can anybody help me how he will
breakthrough in this position
d5 yes C takes d5 he takes d5 and what
tall calculates here or banks on is the
idea that he is more developed than
black so it's just about time to open up
the position in since in when talking
about development flex position is a
little bit dubious from that perspective
before a5 Queen c7 and without
hesitation tall takes on e6 and this is
approved by computers it's a very good
sacrifice and this is the chess what we
will see later on by alphago beat XC 394
now obviously tau makes some mistakes in
this game but the basis of his game is
very sound so rook g8 Queen a for
checking the 8th
and because the threat of rook takes g2
is way too strong the world champion
plays g3 and gets rid of that threat
bishop d5 in here tall plays a very
strong logical move what is that
well white has two pieces attacking rook
t1 of course bringing in some more heavy
artillery King c8 and B takes c3 now
beat a exceeds me is the sort of move
that is very hard to find because you're
looking for a killer blow but you're not
quite there yet Bishop c5 e 7 not one
thing black to take the pawn and also
its retina to clean so knight c6 Bishop
g4 check King B summons only move as
rook takes fails to the simple idea of
cleaning now already we can see this is
a crazy position and notice that tall
played it in 1960 so he plays like the
computer without this the software I
mean hardware King b7 Knight b5 putting
some more fuel on the fire so if you
take my queen will get much closer and
after Bishop b6 I can take Queen takes
b6 and eventually all of your pieces
drop I can just check maybe I can't
check you but take take and minimum
prize I'll take the bishop but I still
will have a good position well actually
Queen takes d5 is just very strong here
not that Queen b6 is too bad
so Queenie five and again tall just
plays logical dominating chess what move
did he find
they look Yvonne first and then he
played this dominating move
Bishop f3 I'll defend with f5 or even
rube g3 which would be more painful no
because I still have rook takes g3 ideas
you don't want to get into rook takes g3
stuff rook takes g3 rugby you want small
moves but very powerful ones Black has
trouble moving the King can't really
take because I'll just take with my
queen and made it soon to follow
let's say here here and I know that the
computer doesn't want to go there but
pin d7 checkmates very very picturesque
position from a human so obviously
Keller didn't want that so it took on g4
rook takes c4 brutal sacrifice Queen
takes c4 96 check double check again
takes takes with Queen D one rookie five
and again another bombshell by tall on
the 29th move rook b7 King takes Queen
d7 King b8 Queens takes takes can be 727
again and Queen takes c6 and basically
Tallis winning and black resigned so I
believe that tall was the forefather or
the main way off of 0 plays and actually
coming back to my example from Blade
Runner ironically tall in 1980 reached
the rating of 2700 which I would really
put in the ballpark of like 2,800 now or
28-30
and if you think tall he reached his
highest peak rating of 2,700 in the
1980s which really doesn't calculate his
salts when he beats Botvinnik in the
1960s and his game results in the 1960s
and 61-year so coming back to offer zero
I have some quotes about that machine
so alpha zero won the match against
stockfish 20 with 28 wins 72 draws and
no losses so this is what some quotes I
got from Twitter and some from chess
calm the spar off said it's a remarkable
achievement even if we should have
expected it after alphago it approaches
the type b human-like approach to
machine chess dreamt of by Claude
Shannon and Alan Turing instead of brute
force and I would agree mostly alpha
zero is going to use the human way of
approaching the game instead of just
calculating Peter Heinonen Olson said
the following seeing the games I thought
well I always wondered how it would be
if a superior species landed on earth
and showed us how to play chess I feel
now how that that would feel so Switzer
also had an opinion about this who is
now an eighth time Russian champion but
was seventh seventh time Russian
champion at that moment he said I do not
belong to the reasonable large group of
people who are seemingly very skeptical
about this achievement so he's not too
skeptical about this result and he gave
this interview to chess 24 Nakamura said
to chess calm it's definitely
interesting
that being said having looked at the
games and the understanding what the
playing strength was I don't necessarily
put a lot of credibility in the results
now to be honest I mostly agree with
Nakamura because even though alphago
plays like an enhanced me halt all and I
think
his level should be around that but I'll
talk about that later on the match
didn't seem totally fair because the
minute was played without opening books
but that kind of favored off ago as
stopped wish his opponent or its
opponent didn't have opening books so it
had to rely on just pour pure hardware
so it's not quite clear if that's not
just an advantage for alphago for no
reason and I'd say that it would be much
fairer to do another match with a
different computer or the same one with
a computer having a good opening book
and we will see in the games how that
affected the match so let's dig in and
take a look at game 1 so yes Knight f3
knight c6 v6 this is the game I talked
about alpha 0 just like me Hotel plays
with Knight f3 c4 in the raita version
version but then transposes Bishop a6
Queen c2 c5 d5 sacrifice now this was
popularized by none other than Alexey
Shirov and also I analyzed this with my
friend INRA Hera and he wrote a very
very good book on this actually and
mentioned as one of the contributors he
takes d5 C takes d5 Bishop d7 Bishop g2
now this is going to be a pawn sacrifice
and it's very admire about that offer
zero found this idea without any proper
opening knowledge on the critical note
though stockfish shouldn't have entered
this position because it's very
dangerous for Black Knight takes d5
castle knight c6 rogue d1 Bishop e7
Queen f5 now notice that there's no rock
takes d5 when
material cuz night before double attack
this is all well known so Queen f5 was
played Knight f6 e for g6 queena for
Castle c5 not a CH 5 now this was
already played in a game between Galvan
and laïkó and also in later games
I mean previous games teenage 6 was
played against laço previously so what
white is playing for here is more of the
play of domination
he doesn't really mind being a pawn down
because this pawn on e5 is just
dominating and stops any pawn breaks the
d6 or f6 and this is much like in the
spirit of me halt all who didn't care as
much about material but about domination
and as we will see alpha zero shows the
human approach of going for domination
in instead of material Queen g4 rook e8
Knight c3 queen bee 895 Bishop f8 well
again the pawn on e5 is taboo because if
you take I take you Queen takes e5 cakes
and the bishop on b7 drops and as this
is just clearly winning for white a 95
Bishop f8 Bishop f4 he doesn't really
mind getting rid of his Bishop because
for exchange for that Bishop he would
get this juicy square of F 6 which would
almost immediately decide the game so
Queen c8 h3 now I find this h3 move
mysterious I don't quite get the idea
maybe to vacate this square for the King
on h2 but that's still hard to explain
and in fact later on we will see alpha 0
loves this h3 h 6 moves for reasons I
don't understand 97
93 now computers would would kind of
disagree in this position stockfish
would say that ok black is better
because of a lot of material advantage
but as humans love domination a lot you
know alpha 0 is basically like a human
on hardware's and he feels that this
should be good enough
Bishop c6 defending that extra pawn on
d7 rook d6 domination number 1 he's
trying to blockade this pawn kind of
deeming it worthless and if you notice
this not on h5 has a trouble moving
around o of black pieces looks more like
a wardrobe than a real position 9g 7 not
a fun move to make again oh they're
trying to untangle that Knight f5 look
at 6 so just like playing checkers he's
trying to get full control of both d6
and after 6 squares and if he manages to
overload blacks position like it's just
going to lose Queen v7 Bishop h6 95 95
very logical trying to exchange them up
material move D 196 inviting some more
exchanges takes takes Queen h4 Bishop c6
Queen 8 6
well not quite there yet but not g5
looms in the air so this night on e6 is
stuck there forever also another idea
that comes to mind as h4 h5 threatening
H takes g6 and also this kind of reminds
me of the famous game played by
shortened Timman where black is kind of
stuck waiting and it has nothing going
for him against the active white pieces
rook e8 rook d6 and now black is in full
nelson as
the rook on d6 f6 and the Queen on h6
just binds black Bishop takes f3 a
little bit of desperation takes Queen a
6h for not really paying attention to
these worthless pawns as he's trying to
do our aforementioned plan of h5 Queen
a5 rook d1 defending against this nasty
check that black was setting up c4 rook
d5 but he's not willing to give away
this anchor this ePHI pawn which makes
White's position superior Queen e1 King
G to C 3 takes takes h5 rookie 7 bishop
d1 now quite realized that the bishop
would have much more firepower here and
just destroy blacks position if the
bishop would manage to enter that square
on b3 Queen e1 Bishop b3 rook the 8th
and looking at this with a human eye
this is totally winning for white rook F
3 Queenie for Queen d2 in G for Bishop
d1 just playing for discoveries planning
this nice little of rook takes f7 trick
black doesn't fall for it because it's a
machine h6 night c7 56 96 just waiting
cuz he doesn't see anything else to do
Bishop b3 Queen takes e5 rook d5 Queen
h8 will be 4 and even though black is
many many pawns up it doesn't mean
anything because this these pieces on d8
and a JIT are just so terrible it just
compensates for the extra two pawns ID
c5 rook takes e5 p takes d5 Queen h4
Mookie 8 over k f6 and what I noticed
when looking through some of
the games of alpha zero and actually
there's only ten that you can find and
look at he goes for domination any time
when it's possible about positional play
well I'm not sure about that it's not as
good as with positions where he can
dominate okay a fade but much more about
that later
Queen f4 in now basically why it is
totally winning because this queen is
just worthless and that's quite a nice
performance by alpha zero just
entrapping this Queen on h8 and black
can only wait to get finished off a for
g4 d5 takes would be seven a for g5 just
cementing that book when I have six just
supported by the spawn on f6 a3 that
does nothing black and white just do
does something that computers rarely do
he's waiting he's not doing anything
he's just saying okay tell me what
you're going to do next
Luke c7 Queen takes a three and black
basically it's stock fish it just gives
up
and after this d4 pawn was slowly
promote and white wins Game two will be
another blowout by alpha zero
and another sacrificial variation and
just to be a bit critical of this match
one thing that stockfish didn't get good
openings and alpha0 did show that it
shines bright so demis hassabis computer
shines greatly and we can see that in
the style of mahal tau alpha zero plays
beautiful chess but the thing that I
didn't notice if how would offer zero
play in positional play and what
stockfish didn't do is have very solid
positions for example never seen games
with d5 g3 Bishop e7 or Bishop b4 check
these are more positional and calm games
that I didn't get to an experience and I
would be really curious what offer zero
would have had in his sleeve or in its
sleeve against it because I admit of a
zero after just four hours of learning
playing these sacrificial lines
it plays brilliantly but I'm more
skeptical about its strengths in
positional positions
he takes d5 Knight h4 and before we go
much further we have to name Grandmaster
who's famous for inventing d5 and his
name is left Beluga offski he put hard
hours of work mainly playing and
preparing against Viktor Korchnoi so he
found this brilliant idea of d5 and this
proves to be a brilliant idea as alpha
zero finds it as the best line in the
position Knight h4 c6c takes d5 Knight
takes d5 Knight f5 we've seen this
position before though this was played
between Kasparov and carp
so Kasparov already had this position in
a world championship match in fact and
what I dislike about this game is that
stock which never really gets the chance
to fight back he already has a crummy
little position and will have to have a
very tough task defending a position
where he has a terrible Bishop on b7
terrible wardrobe like pieces on a 8 and
B 8 n b7 so alpha zero gets the
initiative from the get-go
so it's basically almost over before it
ever started Knights e7 e for Bishop f6
96 again domination what alpha zero goes
goes for is the domination of me halt
all going for a good good piece for a
pawn we should be a six rookie 198 and
if we think like alpha zero what would
be our next move be a five of course
very good move in the style of tall
enough after Knight b6 this table would
do it he'd take the bishop and I'm not
sure it's all inbuilt in computers these
days but Bishop pair in general is worth
upon so that second pawn is compensated
by these two beautiful beasts on g2 and
c1 in takes f6 Knight c3 now black has a
tough time organizing his pieces
yes he's two pawns up but those pawns on
d7 and c6 are just in the way of this
night so it cannot really develop no
wonder black is trying to untangle that
night b7 kind of hoping to play d5 at
some moment 94 bringing some more pieces
in to action and again alpha 0 finds the
best way to
her ass black in this position how can
we harass black and especially the
screen on g6 h4 yes of course
8 6 H 5 pin 8 7 3 g4 are you said Queen
d4 Queen before Oh deeper okay
so cringy for three g4 is very nice move
King h8 Bishop g5 and this is purely a
move not played by computers this is
really it feels that this is the
heritage of top maybe Bronstein so
Bronstein does deserve credit too he
also like these the positional
sacrifices so ok stockfish believes off
a zero but if H takes g5 we'd just take
and if Queen c2 BAM we'll take on f7 if
you take another gift
then you'll regret that badly after
Bishop b4 your days are numbered and
after g6 Queen takes g6 mate nice little
mate and we can see that all these
pieces on 8 b 8b seven and a six didn't
do anything so they're useless and if
black would play queen g8 which no
grandmaster would play because they
would rather resign on the spot then why
it has this move of Queen h4 just
preparing the immediate 86 with the plan
of H takes g7 and any computer would
agree that White has a huge attack if
not just totally winning
so offer zero was believed in stock
which plays that five play that five so
stockfish beta 5 FINA for now it's
impossible to take because I would just
take on f8 night c5 he wants to exchange
some more Bishop e7 and again ID 3 Queen
d6 takes takes what is again not worried
about pieces so this night is kind of
condemned to live a life without ever
entering the game because all of those
squares are taken right now all of these
squares on d6 d7 c6 a6 are taken so
basically black is playing a rook and
Knight down which is never a good thing
F takes e4 Bishop takes e4 look at 5 a
page 4 but is in no hurry because it
will take some quite a few moves for
black to untangled Bishop c4 g4 just
slowly and calmly collecting material
would be 5 takes takes rook e8 Bishop g8
Bishop g3c 525 and why just collects the
extra material and now he's just clearly
winning these six stakes 97 fini for a
very human approach let's just get rid
of your only active piece which is very
passive but it can get aggressive it if
it ever got the chance to bolt out and
go to B 1 or D 3 so Queenie 4 is very
good out of 6 stakes
mouki 7 and let's just enjoy a little
bit of technique from alpha 0 Knight xg4
Luke takes a 7 Knight of 6 Bishop takes
d6
there should be 6 Bishop b5 trying to
tie this bishop tie to trying to just
pin down this Knight 97 Bishop c3 g6
bishop
d - now I find this move a little bit
mysterious I would think that most of
the humans would just take the pawn play
a 3 and B 4 and then that way but off of
0 goes a different way and plays Bishop
d2 let's black take the pawn a3 King g6
Bishop f4 just aiming to attack the b6
pawn king f5 bishops e7 h 4o k 8h v okay
Jay King g6 moved the 8th King f7 well
to be honest I feel that white is kind
of Tang going a little bit not doing too
much just enjoying being some material
up edge 3 will get chick in g6 rook e8
waits Bishop e6 and slowly but surely
white converts he just improved his King
a little bit in now King g1 which is
weird because if I remember correctly
the King started from there so that's
kind of interesting
c4 engage - that's kind of strange takes
Knight a four-night c5 Luke e5 rogue d5
I assumed he didn't want to take the
pawn because he was worried of 94 double
attacking and maybe some play so instead
rook d5 we should be 656 Bishop e1 can
be 5 and now slowly but surely black is
losing
and etc why it manages to win and 497
takes upon and he will win this slowly
but surely so we've seen these games and
want to take a look at game the third
game that I saw this one with d5 and now
this will be a severe test for off a
zero and I'm not really amazed by its
play in these type of positions this
will be more like of a positional
struggle and to be honest I wasn't as
amazed when he was playing tactical
positions when he was playing tactical
positions I think it's really on the
highest level
it's very on the super elite level when
it plays and again it's kind of
unfortunate that they're not playing
with opening books because this d5 is a
very bad move it just closes in this
Bishop on b7 and I have to agree with
Nakamura that stockfish didn't have as
much hardware or the needed opening
books to challenge all four zero and we
could see that the bit moves like d5 and
to really get a good challenge for all
four zero you need to find a computer or
a human that has enough opening
knowledge to go against it now one idea
would be to set up a double blind
tournament with let's say Carlson
Nakamura Corona and Kramnik playing with
computers like stockfish offer zero
Komodo and etc but without any of them
knowing if they're playing a human or a
computer that way we could decide if
their objectives
strength is kind of close or far in
between and also then the psychological
advantage of computers wouldn't matter
at least it wouldn't matter from the
human perspective because when humans
play computers we run into the trouble
of them believing computers of being
faultless which is not true I don't
believe it's true and we will see it in
the upcoming three games so castles
castles see takes a takes Knight c3 all
greats and very natural moves 97 be four
full points for positional play now b4
is trying to build a structure that goes
against the black pawn break at c5 and
this is a very usual positional move
it's known for years it was played many
times in the Corp of kaspar of matches
c6 very natural if b5 then black who
plays c5 and would have this classical I
mean hanging pawns which could be a
weakness but it could also be a positive
2 so Queen B to a5 b5 and the
aforementioned c5 is coming rook c1
clean e7 and to be honest I'd say at the
moment white is slightly better because
of this b6 pawn being a chronic weakness
and offer 0 not surprisingly tries to
jump at it now Ruby it is very natural
comes with rook d1 c4 and Knight e5 now
this position I'd feel that white is
slightly slightly better but not by much
it's slightly better for white but if
black plays correctly it's equal ish and
to be honest with you this is the
nightmare of computer chess it's a house
close
position with nothing really going on
no tactics just slow strategic chess
which humans excel at Queen e6f for good
move stabilizing that beast on e5 mm-hmm
Queen is six okay we froze a little bit
Queenie six F for rook the eight Queen
d2 9 f8 Knight c3 9 g 6 rook F 1 d6
a4 yeah now there's just slow positional
struggle going on nothing really
terribly much rook c8 kind of a weird
move although he's kind of getting rid
of this tactical idea of Knight takes e4
e 397 g4 98 @ 5 f6 Knight f3 now my play
was pretty nice I think it was pretty
good it was a no ok positional way of
playing but black was doing great as
well I think the position should be
around roughly equal but shockingly
white is going to win Queen d7 queen f2
96 doing a little bit of a maneuvering
just putting the night to a better
square Knight d2 another good move I
like this one because it all goes
against these ideas of night the
potential Knight e4 and white just puts
enough pressure so that it will never
happen
rook f8 slightly mysterious but not bad
in g3 rook the 8th look at for now rook
F for I tried to make sense of rook f4
but I still can't
it might want to go against the idea of
Knight e4 but it's not really a threat
and if Knight e4 is not coming
I don't know what this rook is doing on
f4 not f7 rook f2 and actually alpha
zero realized that okay so you're not
jumping on e4 I'll go back not that rook
F 2 does anything Luke e8 Age 3 again
the move I was talking about alpha zero
loves this waiting move even though it
has a function it creates this lift
again on h2 and protects this g4 pawn
queen d6 night f1 okay nothing special
queen 8th me now this is the moment we
need a stronger opponent for offer zero
Queen e3 is clearly not doing much apart
from attacking the rook on c1 so this
move is just one step in the wrong
direction
Brooksie to just getting rid of that
threat h5 a terrible a terrible move so
to be honest with you this position is
roughly equal I wouldn't claim any
advantage for right after Queen d6 it's
roughly equals but h5 is just we would
reprimand anyone who plays h5 this is
just too much even though I've seen
computers suggested that's just too much
you shouldn't be doing that
and now alpha zero slowly starts to get
a grip on the position but before that I
don't think he had any advantage h5
Queen c7 and yep he hits on the weak
spot immediately as the bishop and b6
bond attacked in the same time and now
black is just worse again Queen d6
screen text e6 rook takes D 693 h4 again
not a great idea is just creating a
weakness on g4 it's more of like a
weakness than a strength 9 h5
95 rook f1 King gate 794 look the 8th
King gauge 2 and back is basically
waiting until he loses the pawn takes
takes and slowly black just loses that
he's a pawn down against the computer it
should be just losing and he's just
easily losing now some of these moves
are still weird but okay he's a pawn up
and he's just going to win this game the
exchange pieces look c1 Luke takes c3
and with a terrible bishop on a8 this
shouldn't be terribly hard to win Bishop
f3 Luke 8 7 g6 check gives the pawn
which I still don't understand
rook g6 would be more normal move at
least hoping for something if you move
your King I'll just take your pawn
so some moves are hard to understand buy
stock fish to be honest and okay he won
this game later on and as I mentioned
before computers don't seem to have a
firm grasp of closed positions still
this was the conclusion after the
Kasparov deep blue match and I think it
still holds and we will see it here he
for he five should be five knight of 63
Bishop c5 takes takes Castle 97-90 to
Castle and looking at this it's tough to
play against a Berlin you need to have
some opening knowledge and in this way I
think this was slightly unfair for
stockfish to have to play this or
playing this was unfortunate because
without an opening book it's very hard
to get an advantage for white and
actually I would might like to invite
the audience
to find the move stockfish played if you
haven't seen the game can you give me
some moves you would like to play in
this position Knight c4 that's a very
very logical move
no it wasn't played by stockfish c3
actually he will play C's I mean it will
play seeds me later on in the second
game I mean the other white game he
played he actually played this move
which to me makes zero sense Anna as a
Grand Master I I don't know what white
wants with Queenie one maybe maybe in
the long future before other than that I
don't understand what Queen e1 stands
for f6 Knight c4 rook f7 and looking at
rook f7 is still kind of a strange move
rook e8 would be the natural move with
going with the same plan that offers 0
will find Knight f8 96 but rook f7 is a
little bit strange
look f7 a4 and now i almost understood
what stockfish was banking on trying to
play b4 and then it would make sense
okay so black plays Bishop f8 King H one
night c5 so he so the computer goes to
night c5 and then from there - nighty 6a
596 and now plays a move I don't
understand again from stockfish and i
don't think it's too good either what
could have stockfish come up with in
this position
see three that would drop a pawn so it
doesn't play that
yeah yeah some kingi one would be too
much I think even for stockfish he took
on e5 and to be honest
humans would never do that because in
the long term this just mean just should
lose and it will lose easily and the
other thing I don't understand if you're
playing Queen e1 at least play before in
the future or at least develop your
pieces and after let's say c5 Bishop c3
Knight e3 and the typical game but
Knight e5 feels like the move that you
should never play if you're a computer
watching this from 300 years from now or
a human you shouldn't sacrifice your
night for some vague compensation and I
don't know I still don't know why the
computer decided to take on e5 takes
takes root cap 6 IG 495 rookie 7e 6 and
ok stalkerish is trying to bank on the
structure but it's still a piece c5i for
Queen e8 a takes Bishop takes b7 Queen a
594 just posting this knight on a
healthy square also hitting on c2 beam
c3 Fuki 6 can you take on c5 maybe maybe
yeah yeah yeah I don't know maybe even
liquidating I don't know maybe this is
too much and necessary but it's still
two pieces or just defense the night
somehow just 92 or 96 back
yeah queen c5 still seems like a better
move so it's kind of strange that the
computer decides to play Queen c3 look
e6 Bishop III night C 4 would be 4 B 3 a
5 takes now he took the now it took the
pawn Knight c4g 3 8 6 5 takes another
pawn but now this Bishop will be very
very powerful here Bishop h3 vogue g1 57
creamy 5 in takes Knight X and now why
does have a lot of pawns but this King
on age 1 and the rook on g1 aren't just
terrible night c4 g5 Luke c1 Bishop g7
and this is the usual thing if the
pieces come to alive when g7 and h3 then
the pieces will outweigh the pawns in
the long run ok 8 which is again the
move I don't understand
Knight f3 it should be two bishops III
just again interestingly alpha zero is
just always trying to dominate Bishop d7
92 52 1 G 2 Bishop g4 another form of
domination just engaging the King rook
e1 Bishop d2 look F 1 bouquet - so what
stockfish wanted is after Bishop e2 this
rook F 2 and the rook would capture one
of the part 1 of the bishop
see it played bouquet to h3 takes Bishop
f4 takes Bishop e5 and later stockfish
lost this objectively lost position
against office zero and we come up to
the last game which will be also tough
and as a wrap-up idea I think alpha zero
is brilliant in tactics and in
domination but in closed positions and
positional understanding it there is
still room to improve Knight f3 knight
c6 Bishop b5 alpha 0 is black again
against stockfish d3 Bishop c5 takes
takes castle 97 and c3 comes Castle d4
and I still don't like this plan of c3
d4 because it's illogical black is
hoping to open up to position as the
bishops usually shine in positions which
are open but c3 d4 usually helps the
opening of the position and it will
happen in this game as well Bishop d6
Bishop g5 now this movie is very good at
least stockfish is trying to keep the
position close between e8 I think it's a
question of taste if you want to play f6
or Queen e8 being roughly seam around
equal strength rook e1 f6 Bishop h4
Queen f7 92 a 5 good idea he's trying to
gain some space but moving his pawns
bishop g3 Luke e8 now why could start
opening up the position but as we talked
about it earlier that's not a great idea
Queen c2 not f8 hinting on ideas of
going to e6 or g6 depending on White's
plan c4 c5
d 5 and the position closed up b69 h4g 6
taken away this F juicy f5 square knot
f3 back Bishop d7 rook a d1 now
everything so far was fairly logical
maybe stockfish could have considered of
closing off this side of the board just
for fun
stopping black from any any potential
idea of gaining space on the Queen side
rook d1 again we can see that the
computers will start struggling in this
type of position shrub d1 move actually
doesn't do anything for example what
could we do in this position as humans
what kind of plans can be for do for
what yes for what it's not that easy
it's true but I think it's possible yeah
yeah so white could have played h3 mm
let's say if just black passes night f1
night each to this way and maybe
planning f3 or f4 later on f4 is a bit
risky but it's an idea so that's
something that could have been played
but rook d1 is a mysterious move it
makes no sense because the position will
never open up rookie 7 okay so he's kind
of planning to double h3 Queen g7 now in
these positions and sometimes that lost
what the computers are trying to do
queen g7 doesn't make sense after rookie
7 at least if it would have brought the
rook on e e8 that would make sense
pin g7 it feels like moves are just made
randomly yeah
yeah I mean it
yeah if yeah Queen g7 as you mentioned
you're correct if black is to do eight
six nine h7 rook f8 f5 it would make
perfect sense but let's watch what they
they're going to do Queen C 3 mu k e8
and from a human perspective this makes
no sense at all if you want if you move
your queen to g7 why didn't you bring
your work to f8 so that's kind of a
mystery to me Queen C 3 bouquet eight
which a3 h6
so that's a good move so I see some
positional intelligence in the position
which is not unheard of from an AI
machine Bishop age for rook f7 Bishop g3
and what will offer 0 play in this
position I ask you
f5 I might have too many pieces line
them against me three nine eight seven
yeah that would make sense but it plays
rook fe7 which makes no sense at all
because okay it would make some sense if
we say that the position is equal yeah
okay
Bishop h4 Luke f7 bishop g3 and now a
four okay I understand that the computer
maybe wants to play a five but it's
fairly logical to choose a different
plan
so Bishop h4 comes here
Luke f7 a for King gage font Luke e7
bishop age for true cap seven I still
don't understand why are they're
shuffling back and forth it in this
position my first thought would be going
g5 9 g 6 H 5 and G 4 that's my first
idea going rookie 7 and rook F 7 the
computers have the luxury of making this
okayish moves but if it will be a king's
indian you don't have the luxury for
these move these kind of moves so rookie
7 bishop now alpha0 decides to play g5
bishop g 396 i would assume that he's
trying to go h5 g 4 or just hopping with
the Knight to f4 and the reason i'm kind
of perplexed with blacks play is that
black is clearly better he should be or
it should be pushing but it doesn't and
just waited with the rooks but okay he
plays g5 not G six-night f1 rook f7
again which I don't understand much 97
Queen d3 h5 okay so he wants to play it
wants to play g4 h 4g
Knight c8 hmm rookie to G for green
eight seven okay kind of hinting at
ideas on a for King G one Bishop outfit
aha okay so there is yes
positional intelligence there the night
is going to d6 so it doesn't really want
to jump on f4 decides to jump on d6
instead not be one Knight c3 Bishop h6
rook F 1 and we can stay that plaque is
just much much better okay eight King
gauge to king of faith Kim Ji Won mean
g6 and alpha 0 is just slowly improving
the position and this is better for a
human and this is better for a computer
as well now for I don't like f4 stock we
should have just sitted and waited and
for takes rook after he takes King g7
and now as the black king went all to
that peaceful square of e7 is ready to
launch an attack with rook g8 Bishop e1
Queen eight seven route g7 takes takes
the exchange of rooks but the weakness
is on e4 and c4 will tell 92 Bishop g4
King gage to King b7 b 3 again not move
that I'd consider it
mostly helps black takes takes in g6 92
Bishop d1 9 f3
I don't know can't we take on e4 god we
can't because the bishop is hanging
sorry
Bishop a4 92 King g7 bishop f2 green G
for green a3 you should be one takes
takes
a four not b7 ib1 not a five this should
eat three
this is positionally lost four why by
now but bishop 'yes we still as a move
you've never considered I'd still would
try at least to defend the c4 pawn and
hope for the best
okay I will lose it but at least I'd try
so Bishop III doesn't make any sense I
don't think it does it's already lost
though Bishop d7 Knight c3 and alpha
zero that's a machine
slowly but surely takes all the ponds
and wins this opposite colored end game
which should be trivial as the as he is
it has to past pawns you get five King
e6 and stockfish resigned because with
side passers it's not likely that y can
save this game so all in all I think off
zero has the rating of a human rating of
28 30 so it's like an elite human not
close to 32,000 that they claimed I
think 3,200 thank you so not anyway
close to 3200 because for one stocked
fish was giving a lot of points away as
we seen in the previous three games
stock which had equal positions just
threw away the games with terrible moves
like h5 and queen a3 so alpha 0 is a
wonderful and could potentially be reach
it could potentially reach 3,000 levels
when looking at me halt I like games but
it's like a 2828 30 level human player
when playing a positional chess
even I'd even prefer humans in these
close positions but still a great
performance file for 0 so looking
forward for more matches
with offer 0 and from stockfish thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]